hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i'm
sure you've noticed the little gaps in
videos since i've started putting
together this studio space this sort of
video shooting space uh but i figured
since it's taking up so much of my time
might as well do a video about it or a q
a and talk about it so i asked you guys
on twitter what you guys want to see or
what questions you have at all about a
video studio or this particular spot and
uh this is what we got how do you get
wi-fi coverage in all parts of the
studio well it is essentially just one
big open space so there's no walls or
anything in between the one router and
any part of the studio so there's a
great connection everywhere this is the
router that we're using it's been great
and that's what allows me to get speeds
like this do you think it's better to
partition it or leave it as one giant
space honestly that's probably toss up
for any studio i think for me i
personally i like being able to see like
all of it at once so i don't have any
partitions it's just one big space right
now for me but for recording audio you
tend to want to have a smaller area with
less reverberation so i will be working
on that just for recording audio how
long did it take to build your mega desk
so the mega desk if you guys don't
already know it's this it's the custom
nextdesk air pro i already did a video
about a next desk this one's just a
bigger version of it but it didn't
actually take that long so i've already
talked about next desk and honestly with
a lot of the stuff you're building in a
studio if you're putting things together
it's really just about the number of
parts that you have to put together so
like this
this is like 400 pieces i'm still not
done with this it's still being built
that was probably like nine i built it
in like an hour it was on my snapchat
story it was actually pretty easy i have
nothing to ask
uh once your studio is done are you
going to do a tour of it i kind of like
the idea of it and i actually kind of
need a use for a 360 degree video and i
was thinking maybe thumbs up below if
you like the idea i was thinking a 360
degree video of the tour where i like
walk around the camera and show you
stuff and i don't know seems like a cool
idea but anyway yes i probably will do a
full tour when the things done how did
you plan out the layout of where
everything will go do you just guess as
you go along or make a plan so with me i
actually sketched out on my ipad pro
with the pencil of like the outline of
the floor plan and where i wanted things
to be and i'm kind of following that now
it's kind of easier to just go with the
way it looks well in the room uh not the
most scientific thing ever but i did
actually sketch it out and i have ideas
for where certain things will go certain
sets certain looks certain ways to take
advantage of the light coming in from
one side kind of have a plan how do you
sound proof it so there is no echo all
right so as you can probably tell i'm
definitely still working on that but
there are a bunch of different ways to
essentially it's not even soundproofed i
mean this room isn't soundproof from the
rest of the world but there's a bunch of
ways that you can reduce the amount of
echo and the amount of bouncing off the
wall that the sound can do before it
gets back into the microphone you want
the only way for audio to get into the
microphone to be straight from the
source so behind the camera i'll take a
picture because i can't even really show
you guys but behind the camera
i have some foam pieces and that will
hopefully stop the sound from going past
the camera and back into the back of the
microphone but it'll still you know
bounce off the side walls and i have
foam on the ceiling and there's some
rugs and there's furniture and there's
all sorts of other things to dampen the
sound but with the space this big you
can never really sound proof it it's
just a matter of positioning things in a
way to reduce the echo as much as
possible it's the hardest part of
starting your office over from scratch
so it's actually not that bad for me i
kind of enjoy the process of setting up
something new like you get a new
computer you know you drop a fresh
wallpaper on it you get all your apps
installed get everything logged in set
up for the first time like it feels
fresh and new i kind of enjoy that
process so it's not so bad i guess the
worst part would just be just all the
building of things that come some
assembly required why fake grass why not
real ones man if i had real plants in
here
it would all die i mean i have the grass
in here because it's green and green is
a nice color on camera and it's kind of
cool to have some different colors in
here once in a while but yeah i don't
think i could keep it alive for very
long if it was real what is the one
thing you plan on doing to your studio
that you haven't seen before that will
be truly unique to you honestly most of
what i'm putting together has probably
been done already aside from the
literally custom stuff that's built to
order most of it has been already done i
think the most unique thing is probably
going to be how i use the things that
i'm using like again this wardrobe here
for example when you buy it from ikea
it's mostly for people who are buying it
to put clothes in it i'm buying it and
putting shelves in it to be able to put
video gear and stuff like that so using
things as a youtuber most of the time is
different from using things as a normal
person other than that most of the
techniques i'm getting or like the
places i'm putting things it's been done
before what do you plan on putting on
the walls any art yes of course i will
definitely be having lots of art in here
uh and so justin mallor who you've
already seen the art by is hooking me up
with some stuff that's already gonna
look really good
but also some other stuff you probably
haven't even seen before to hopefully
look dope in the backgrounds on the
walls the blank walls can only be so
interesting to so many people so yeah we
got some stuff coming in to add some
color to this space is there a lot of
natural light in your new studio or do
you have to use artificial lighting so
this particular space does have an
entire wall of windows which is a ton of
natural light that's probably not normal
for a studio i think most photographers
and some video people prefer to be able
to control all the light and not have
the clouds moving in and out so they
like to have their own soft boxes and
everything but i have preached before
and i've said i love shooting with
natural light all the time so anytime i
can get outside and shoot in a park or
use the sun all that light is free and i
don't worry as much about the variation
just because i think it looks that much
better one of my biggest tips for video
especially when you're recording an
object like a smartphone for example is
to focus on that object looking good
with lighting first so before the camera
or the lenses or the audio which are all
really important is to just get the
object to look as good as possible
before the camera even turns on so
photography is the capturing of light
video being the moving photography i
think just having that look as good as
possible before you turn the camera on
is a big skill how long did it take you
to put together that huge wardrobe so
this thing this wardrobe right here is
called the ikea pax system it's pretty
much again custom because you get to
choose all the shelves and stuff you put
inside of it i chose a bunch of
different things but then you have to
build it also i got it on monday
and i'm still building it it's thursday
does having a separated studio and
apartment make you more productive so
that's a good question i thought about
that a lot for myself i do think having
a separate place to live and shoot makes
me more productive i kind of you know
when you're a youtuber you tend to
especially a lot of other youtubers
you'll roll out of bed
into the place where you do work like
you do videos so it's so easy to just
sort of roll back into bed and back into
not working mode so i think for me it
actually helps when i get excited and i
have a video i want to make i have to go
get in the car and drive to the place to
make the video so obviously it'll take
an extra second to actually get here but
yeah i feel like having a dedicated
space to work on this one thing will let
me be more productive when i'm here
mkbhd edition pool table or ping pong
let's just start with an mkbhd edition
poker table and then just see where that
goes we'll see where that goes if you
could put any one piece of furniture in
your studio what would it be okay so you
know the dream desk from the video over
at john at tld did a couple of weeks
back
that is one of my favorite pieces of
furniture of all time
that's from a company called roach
bebois this is not a plug for them or
anything but i did order one
it takes 12 to 16 weeks to build it they
build everything super custom so that's
like the one piece of furniture i'm
really excited for that i'm waiting for
you won't even see it here until like
august you'll probably forget it even
exists but when it shows up on video
though
it's gonna be sick anyway that's pretty
much it thank you for watching thank you
for your questions and feel free to
follow the twitter or the snapchat story
of course if you want to see the
progress of the stuff that's being built
in the studio every day but uh yeah
that's pretty much it i'm gonna head off
to san francisco to google i o and then
there will be videos from there then
i'll come back and build some more
anyway there you go thanks for watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace